so the destiny beta is underway and
you're probably all out there using
shotguns and space magic to romp or
stomp your way through all the Dougs
Vinnie's and cue balls that are crapping
up the earth what you know nickname your
enemies you got to but while you can
bludgeon your way through a horde of
thrall pretty easily there are places
where other things can punch through you
pretty easily these are the secret
bosses of the destiny beta some protect
treasure others just want to be left
alone
but almost all of them can kill you in
one hit let's go introduce ourselves
shall we find one of these two buildings
located close to your moth yards drop
point and head downstairs until your
ankle deep in sewage maybe this pack of
hallowed acolytes thinks it's a motor
something I don't know they're not super
friendly
skedaddle pass them into this back room
to grab a loot chest and when you
inevitably die at their hands you'll get
a glimpse of what their question marks
level actually is 18 a pretty solid and
what point in your leveling would you
say that you became amused all my
weapons I see no further questions time
to get the F out of here but not before
grabbing a few loot chests that are
scattered around including this one
tucked away up in the rafters back
topside it's time to go cave cruising
there are some empty dead ends here and
there but this glowing one at the end of
this airplane wing has a dead ghost for
you to collect and a manageable bad guy
for you to slay continuing along the
road takes us to this cave which has
absolutely nothing for you to collect
and a few very unmanageable bad guys who
will slay you not worth it
there is worthwhile exploration to be
done through the canyon though starting
with this chest behind the waterfall
because video games this is actually one
of the five golden chests mentioned on
the map of old Russia so you'll probably
get something pretty neat motor along
down the canyon towards rusty boat land
and ignore this first cave area up to
the right all it's waiting for you there
is a couple of level 11 doug's and a
heaping helping of death anew thank you
okay boat time all aboard for heinous
and swift death in the bowels of an old
busted boat yard building thing swab the
deck of these low-level bad guys and
head downstairs to find some hallowed
knights and a celebrant of Oryx who will
celebrate after punching your head in
with one swipe better than getting
tea-bagged though which these guys
totally do nothing of material worth in
there though so feel free to skip it and
go hunting for the golden chest that
lies just above the waterline way out
this away then head back the other way
and travel into the narrow canyon that
takes you to the grotto when you spot
dudes you better jack be nimble yourself
out of the way or prepare to boogie down
in respawn town there's a dead ghost
down the path to the left but the weird
stuff is at the top of the hill yeah
there's a bunch of acolytes here that
could kill you in one shot but what is
this thing right here oh yeah this thing
weird right
it's a striker I guess and what would
you say you do here exactly mr. striker
oh yes
kill things of course what else neat
heading into the cave past this weird
alien thingy you'll find a horde of
weird alien thingies who are all way too
high level for you there's a bunch of
acolytes a couple wizards you definitely
shouldn't be trying to punch anyone in
here which means you should definitely
try to punch someone in here because
otherwise they're gonna think you're
weak there's not actually anything of
value in here as far as I could tell but
never underestimate the intangible fun
of seeing some weird [ __ ] like these
glowing pulsing sigils what is that all
about can we get a translator in here
anybody even though it's just a beta
there's plenty more to see out in the
wilds of destiny so go exploring why
don't you if you find any cool spots in
your exploration or
any cool spots for that matter and that
game was good let folks know in the
comments below check the comments
yourself to see if there's anything you
missed and then get back out there and
find more weird stuff to get murdered
bye